is the three you know it is an art isn't
it
to coaching superstars grant you've been
a
superstar you've kind of fulfilled
different roles in your
career but there is an art to that
they're having too much fun now they're
cutting up now no
man you can't you can't embarrass me
like that stop it
yeah i saw that i saw he went he would
uh he went hibachi on him
nice finish there on the other end for
john wall
that was like gilbert arenas right there
shoot the three and turn and look at his
bench
that's the kind of night b-hay wood that
lebron james
and a double at a pump fake before that
come on man it's disrespectful right
there but that's fun too
it's fun if you're if you're it's fun if
you're on the lakers side and you gotta
understand you got to bring your own
energy it's a nice take by john
you got to bring your own energy and get
the bench involved but if you're houston
and you see that
that's got to be the rallying cry that
brings you back into this game you got
to have the pride like listen okay i
know you guys are beating me
but now you're trying to embarrass me we
got to ratchet it up and show that
we're not gonna let these guys embarrass
us out there
[Applause]
well this should be interesting the rest
of the ways lebron is just
absolutely scorching the rockets
and doing it in many ways he got
sterling brown on his hip blows right
by him at an and one opportunity and
that's what i like ba
i mean obviously you have to mix it up
when you're in the post
but lebron it's 6-8 260.
i love him getting that ball in the post
and mid post and attacking getting into
the paint
you cannot guard him when he does that
he hits that fade away which is an
incredibly difficult shot
but when he is attack and gets in that
paint he's going to get to the line and
of course a strong possibility for a
three-point play
all right let me throw this at you guys
as well lebron
it doesn't seem like at least with his
current makeup of this roster
doesn't seem like he's gonna have to
carry
the biggest burden anymore he's still
going to carry a huge burden
but there are nights when he's not going
to have to and it feels like this is a
much more rounded team with a much
better bench
in the lakers and the world champions he
got even better
by the way they put this team together
around lebron this past
offseason got a timeout on the floor
hold that thought
all lakers and lebron james tonight he
scored the last seven
he's just having fun with houston right
now corner three
he's got seven teams that's how we did
it in the summer at carmichael
stop playing